hallo mein Name ist Luca meine Damen und
Herren ich bin heute für einen Tag
Polizist
los geht's ja chilliger Tag bisher als
Polizist ist es gerade 8:07 Uhr am
Montag dem 07.11.2022 und wir verlassen
jetzt erstmal den schreibt viel zu tun
in New York City ne z.B den Müll
entleeren
geht nicht
[Musik]
wir laufen mal raus aus unserem Büro und
sehen hier schon die ersten Verdächtigen
ja sie haben doch wieder ermordet
die halten wir doch erstmal fest wegen
einer unerlaubten Straße Überquerung
überquert haben nein bin ich nicht sie
müssen sichern
[Musik]
Verfolger geflohen sind sie machen Witze
nee das ist hier kein Spaß das ist die
Realität ab in Knast jetzt mit dir
Gefangenentransport rufen
ein wenig gelegene Einheit wird an Ihren
aktuellen Standort geschickt ja ich bin
im Polizeirevier ihr habt wen ermordet
und ist über eine rote Ampel auf der
Straße illegal gelaufen dafür stehe ich
mit meinem Namen das ist ein erster
Arbeitstag und deine erste Schicht
besteht darin Strafzettel auszustellen
Alter also nach Fahrzeugen ausschaue die
gegen parkvorschriften verstoßen sei
wachsam und sei gepräsenz wenn Du
weitere Verstöße feststellst denk daran
du musst einen Anfangsverdacht haben
bevor du jemanden festhältst und einen
hinreichenden Verdacht mit hinreichendem
Beweis bevor du diese Person auch
verhaften kannst
in dieser Stadt sorry noch mal ne viel
Spaß dann im Knast ich plädiere für
lebenslänglich hier sind die Zellen
können wir da rein nee wenn man nicht
ist irgendjemand aha was hat sie denn
gemacht komm komm hier rein
ich checks irgendwie noch nicht so ganz
ach guck mal der Drogen die davon leben
an genau okay wir gehen mal raus würde
ich sagen hier vorne geht's lang und
sind draußen
immer wie viel wollen die mir noch voll
labern
ich kann das übernehmen das Parkplatz
ist
du hast deinen ersten CP verloren weil
du dich bei deiner letzten Begegnung
nicht richtig verhalten hast was
die gehört in den Knast dieses Auto hier
steht ja komplett falsch hier da rufen
wir erstmal direkt an meinen aktuellen
Standort
ist derzeit nicht erreichbar wir
schicken so schnell wie möglich einen
raus mein Standort ist nicht erreichbar
wollt ihr mich verarschen als eine
Einfahrt hier vorne liegt Geld
nee das sind kippen oder so hier liegt
auch Müll ey das ist doch unfassbar wie
hier das äh oh Schmuck
[Musik]
leicht
können wir das ja der Dame kaufen die
wir fälschlicherweise ins Gefängnis
gepackt haben aber sie gehört auch hin
von wegen das gegen die kriegt gar
nichts außer Brot und Wasser was macht
er hier der Park doch auch falsch so
Strafzettel weil
kommen ernst da steht nur parking nur
von 8 bis 12 Uhr achso nee nur dann darf
man da parken nehmen und dann
kann es sein dass du dumm bist
von der Seite an
zurück grüßen ab Handschellen anlegen
wegen Betäubungsmittel und Alkohol und
Drogenmissbrauch am Steuer alkoholein
Polizisten zu grüßen menschlich gesehen
ziemlich abstoßend sind dran deswegen
fragen wir jetzt erstmal nach dem
Personalausweis bitte
schauen wir uns das mal an hier ist er
wie heißt er denn oder sie er was geht
Organspender der deal-locker damit wir
könnten ihn jetzt durchsuchen ich würde
allerdings sagen dass wir
sicherheitshalber erstmal den gefangen
danke schön so lange warte ich hier mit
dem
was macht sie denn sie hat mich auch
gerade angerempelt ne Handschellen
erstmal dran Betäubungsmittel
kannst du direkt mitfahren guck mal da
vorne haben wir doch schon die Einheit
oder ja hier rüber Jungs die beiden hier
die haben hier gedealt die beiden müssen
ganz ganz schnell ins Gefängnis kommt
nachher Jungs schnell ab komm rüber
Steve komm lauf lauf sehr gut sehr gut
da vorne sind sie die beiden
nicht zum Streifen sehr gut ja haben sie
nicht also wer mich hier grüßt das
wirklich falsch so viel Spaß euch im
Gefängnis er hier kriegt jetzt erstmal
noch einen Abschleppdienst könnt ihr
einen Abschleppwagen in meinen aktuellen
Standort schicken ich habe hier einen
Wagen der abgeschleppt werden muss
ein Abschlepper wird in ein paar Minuten
eintreffen perfekt okay hier geht's halt
was macht er denn
ich würde sagen wir beobachten ihn
erstmal unauffällig
[Musik]
der hecklocker gerade irgendwas hier
vorne haben wir irgendein komisches
Denkmal können wir das Denkmal auch
verhaften
du hast eine neue Sehenswürdigkeit
entdeckte riesiger Kopf
er hier vorne ist auch am Handy und was
ist das
ich habe schon wieder 10 CP abgezogen
bekommen komplett aus hallo
alte Dame was soll das
Handschellen anlegen wegen Tatort Raum
begangen haben ja bitte tun Sie das
nicht doch ich bin Polizist und ich muss
die Straßen von New York City sicherer
machen
[Musik]
also sorry das geht gar nicht ne
braune Schuhe zu einem komplett
schwarz-weißen Outfit
Handschellen anlegen
Tatort schwere Körperverletzung eine
schwere Körperverletzung begangen haben
das Outfit ist
Körperverletzung also erst festgenommen
sie ist festgenommen sie da vorne steht
auch noch Rum da kommt aber gleich einen
Streifenwagen mal schauen was sie hier
macht wird ziemlich andere wenn ich mich
hier hinstelle
ja was soll das hier
ich habe keinen Handschellen mehr
[Musik]
der beste Polizist der Stadt ist einfach
zurück meine Damen und
ich würde sagen dass wir bei ihr dann
einfach nur ein Verstoß bestrafen und
zwar wegen Vandalismus
eine mündliche Verwaltung bei einer
mündlichen Verwarnung danke
kein Problem
mal rauskommen hier ganz kurz hallo
hallo hallo hallo
[Musik]
hallo raus hallo stehen bleiben stehen
bleiben hallo hallo hallo hallo hallo
hallo
stehen bleiben
[Musik]
[Applaus]
oh mein Gott der läuft auf der Straße
ist ja hallo
Officer Laser zum Luca hier am Start ach
so
ich brauche halt neue Handschellen ne
Moment Partner ich wollte fragen ob ich
ein paar Handschellen haben kann ist das
gerade dein scheiß ernst du bist mit
Abstand der schlechteste Polizist
gewesen den wir jemals hatten du bist
für alle Ewigkeiten gekündigt und jetzt
zieh deine loser luca du hast alle
Verhaltens Punkte verloren und wurdest
entlassen
[Musik]
äh ja ich bin ja eh gefallen